there must have been some great college
fraternity party last night I can't
remember a thing wait how did I get home
and why do my parts hurt hold it right
there the reason you can't remember what
happened to you last night
it's because somebody gave you roofies
are you saying I got raped last night
yes that's exactly what I'm saying
you got raped but it's like the saying
goes rape me once shame on you rape me
twice shame on me
next time try wearing genuine police Tek
2000 rape shield undergarments cannot be
opened without their coded infrared
controller wow those look well-made
trust me once you've been not raped
twice police Tek rape shield
undergarments have paid for themselves
so remember you don't have to be a super
model to get raped police Tek 2000 rape
shield undergarments sound just
sound like just the ticket say a rape
safety
[Music]